E. Lockhart & Maureen Johnson: Good morning
Hank!
John: Those are world-famous writers Maureen
Johnson and E. Lockhart. By the way, the Brotherhood
2 website looks awesome.
It's 6:30 in the morning, I am extremely tired,
and I have a long day of writing ahead of
me. So we're gonna make this quick, and we're
gonna do it school style.
First period: Math. I would like to briefly
explain the 70/42 mishap. What happened was
that I incorrectly believed, and indeed have
always believed, that each minute contains
100 seconds. Were that to be true, there would
be 70 5-second segments in each 3 minute and
30 second period.
It turns out, and this is extraordinarily
difficult news for me to accept, that each
minute only contains sixty seconds, and therefore
there's only 42 5-second segments in each
3 minute and 30 second period. This is a tragedy
not only for the American minute, but also
for me personally. It makes the fact that
the first draft of my new novel is due in
8,640 minutes 40 percent more terrifying.
Second period: It's supposed to be history,
but your teacher is lazy and all you ever
do is watch TV shows he taped. Hank, I feel
like one of my duties to you, as the brother
who does own a working television, is to keep
you informed periodically about what's going
on in the world of entertainment. Paula Abdul
has a drug problem. Ivanka Trump is improbably
attractive.
Period Three: Physical Education. Hank, the
Bears are just one game away from the Superbowl,
and if I have my way, I will be filming Brotherhood
2.0 from the Superbowl.
Fourth Period: English. Hank, your Battle
of the Books inspired me to have my own Battle
of the Books because I thought that your Battle
of the Books was hilarious, and then I thought
maybe my Battle of the Books could be kind
of like a pale imitation, and people would
laugh and say "well, it's good, but it's not
as funny as Hank's" and you know, that's pretty
much my goal with this thing.
Round one: The American edition of Looking
for Alaska versus the Dutch edition of Looking
for Alaska.
(American): Hey, how's it goin?
(Dutch): OK, how are you?
(American): Hey, why don't you have an accent?
(Dutch): Uh, I don't, I don't do accents,
I think they're weird.
(American): AAAHHHRRRAAARAARAA (pants)
(in high voice): Oh wait, no! It's the Danish
edition of Looking for Alaska! Dodadoodadoodadooo!
And the British edition! Wait are the British
on the American sides? Or are they on the
Dutch sides? Oh my God, they're for Europe,
not America!
It wasn't until I started editing that that
I realized: Oh my God, I am such a loser.
I can't even bring myself to show you the
Hemingway versus Faulkner one, it's even more
embarrassing.
Announcements: Hank, could you possibly mail
me some of the misprinted EcoGeek business
cards, just like, five of them? Thanks. You
can get my address from Mom and Dad. Also,
can we agree to have our Happy Dance compilation
video done around the end of February?
Okay, okay, okay. Big day, big day, big day,
big day. 2,000 words, 2,000 words, 2,000 words,
2,000 words. Okay, I'm gonna go back to bed.